[music]
>> Fundamental to effective communication
is being heard. I'm at Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to this Quick Thinks episode of
Think Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast. I'm
often asked, how can I make sure my
voice is heard? People aren't wondering
how do they insert it into a
conversation. They literally want to
understand how can my volume go up? So
today I'd like to have a conversation
about volume. And you can't have a
conversation about volume without
talking about breath.
Then we'll talk about how to expand your
volume, build vocal stamina, and finally
we'll conclude to talk about how
microphones can help you communicate
better.
Your voice is a wind instrument.
The more you do with it, the more your
volume and voice can be affected by it.
We need to think about how we breathe to
help us project our voice.
Many of us when we get nervous or or
uncertain, we breathe shallow and tight
in the upper chest. We also breathe very
quickly. This changes our ability to
project our voice. You have to be able
to fill your lower abdomen to support
your voice fully.
Something you can do in the privacy of
your own space to figure out where
you're breathing from is to put one palm
on your upper chest and one on your
lower abdomen.
If I'm speaking from my upper chest as
I'm doing now, I feel vibration and a
little movement here and nothing in my
lower abdomen.
But when I take a deeper breath and
speak lower and sometimes slower, I
actually feel a lot of movement here and
a little vibration in my upper chest.
So, to help build that awareness of
where your breath is coming from, give
yourself a sensory experience of it.
Another way to help you learn about your
breathing is to read out loud. Reading
out loud is a proxy for speaking out
loud. And the benefit of reading out
loud is you can focus on your breathing
because the words are presented right in
front of you. I don't care what you
read. It can be something for work, for
pleasure, can be email, a magazine, does
not matter.
By reading out loud and really paying
attention to where the breath is coming
from, you can gain more control of it.
And the more control you have over it,
the better able you are to project.
So, lower, slower breathing gives you
more vocal support so you can project
your voice.
Now, there's a really interesting
technique that I learned from a acting
professional.
While I'm not an actor myself, I really
like this technique.
Rather than just thinking about
projecting your voice forward,
actually pick a place where you want to
put your voice. So, imagine you're in a
conference room sitting around a large
table, you're at one end, and there are
people far away from you. Instead of
just broadcasting out,
focus your voice in front of the person
who's sitting farthest from you.
In doing so, it changes you the
structure of your body. You'll tend to
open up more, you'll breathe more
deeply, and you'll be able to position
your voice so it'll be louder. So, it's
not about broadcasting it out, it's
about focusing on placing your voice in
a certain space.
I I to body posture just a moment ago,
and this is really important. You want
to open your body as much as possible.
Many of us, especially when when we're
on virtual calls, we hunch over and
close our body off.
That reduces the oxygen.
In fact, many actors and actresses or
professional speakers before they go out
on stage and project, they'll work on
stretching their body and opening it up.
That's a great great place for us to
start.
Once we have the mechanics and the
breath, we have to work on stamina.
Very few of you would wake up one
morning and say, "I'm going to go run a
marathon." and just start running.
If you wanted to run a marathon, you'd
train first. And the same thing is true
with your voice and vocal projection.
If you're going to speak for 5, 10, 30,
60 minutes, you should build vocal
stamina.
Because most of us can start out strong,
but can we sustain it so we can continue
to project our voice?
Best way to do this, again, is reading
out loud. Reading out loud to build
vocal stamina is like running on a
treadmill to build your stamina for
running a road race. So, if you know you
have a 30-minute presentation that you
have to give in a week or two, you
should start reading out loud for 5 or
10 minutes a day to build that stamina
so you can project your voice all the
way through.
And you want to make sure that you have
the energy at the end of your
communication
as well as at the beginning. Many of us
start energetic and excited, and because
we're speaking for so long, we lose our
wind. We lose that energy. By building
vocal stamina, you'll continue to have
the energy and be able to project your
voice.
Now, fortunately, we live in a world
where there's technology that can help
us project our voice. Microphones are
very useful for helping you not just
record what you're saying, but to make
sure your voice is projected. Now, we
have to use microphones appropriately.
The first type of mic I want to talk
about is a lavalier mic, a lav. This is
a little microphone that usually gets
clipped right under your chin.
Now, it tends to have a cord and a
battery pack. You have to be careful and
make sure that you're prepared for that
cuz often you'll drop the cord through
your shirt and you need to have a place
to clip the battery pack or a pocket to
put it in. I've worked with some
speakers who came dressed in a way that
did not allow for those to easily be
done.
When it comes to a lavalier, you want to
make sure it's about 6 in
away from your mouth.
And because it is fixed, you want to
make sure that your head stays in the
same position. So, if the lavalier is
here and I turn over here, notice I've
increased the distance and unless you
have somebody working the sound board
that is controlling the volume, your
voice will get quieter. So, if you have
a lavalier mic, you simply turn your
whole body so you keep the orientation
the same.
So, make sure you have something to clip
it to, both the mic and the pack. And
try to keep your head in relationship to
the mic the same so your volume stays
the same.
Now, sometimes when you're speaking, you
actually have a microphone.
Handheld mic needs to be kept at the
same distance from your mouth so that
the volume stays the same and you make
the life of the sound board operator
much easier. So, lightly hold the mic.
Some people clutch it because they're so
nervous. Lightly hold the mic, put your
elbow against your body. This is the
only time I ever encourage people to
connect the elbow to the body. Usually
when gesturing, we want it away.
And I gesture with the other hand.
Notice I'm keeping the distance about 6
in the same.
Now, if I want to switch hands, which is
a good thing cuz this arm might get
tired. I come to the mic, keep the mic
in the same place, and gesture with the
other hand.
Some mics have cables, and you need to
be careful with where the cable is. I
saw a speaker once trip over the cable,
embarrassing for them and dangerous.
So, if you're using a handheld mic, hold
it in place, gesture with the other
hand, and again, come back to it.
These are all techniques that will help
you project your voice and make sure
your point is heard.
We want to think about body posture and
breathing. We want to think about
placing our voice. We want to make sure
we build that vocal stamina to support
our energy and volume throughout what we
say. And finally, we want to leverage
microphones appropriately to help us
make sure we're heard.
Thank you for joining me for this quick
thinks episode of Think Fast, Talk
Smart, the podcast. To learn more about
voice, please listen to episode 262 with
Patsy Rodenburg. This episode was
produced by Catherine Reed, Alex
McCarthy, Ryan Campos, and me, Matt
Abrahams. Our music is from Floyd Wonder
with special thanks to the Stanford GSB
video crew. Thanks also to Podium
Podcast Company. Please find us on
YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and rate
us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn, TikTok,
and Instagram. And check out smarter.io
for deep dive videos, English language
content, and our newsletter. Please
consider joining our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community at
smarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, an AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's faster smarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Woo!